you
efore I'm not gonna do the French this
time let's go with let's go with E 5 not
really a big fan of a 5 in response to e
4 kind of have to be prepared for a lot
of different gambits I don't know that
I'm really so prepared like look at this
look at this like I think I'd just push
here with d5 I don't want to do D 6
that's way too passive let's do this
let's see what happens
so one of the differences beats well we
both have wood thrown a couple ponds up
here in the center one of the
differences between white and black is
well this isn't a developing move both
these pawn advances are helping both my
bishops so black a white might need to
be a bit cautious about their King more
so than mine
if pawn takes this is what I had a plan
to do as e4 move and this really isn't
my type of game it's really not think I
pin the knight like these gambit type of
Miller's I think just rapid development
is a top top priority and having said
that I believe I need to get my bishop
out in full force and by pinning the
knight then have more pressure or I
could recapture on e5 mm-hmm what about
that
hmmm I just take pod push seems kind of
appealing I'm just gonna do it I'm down
to pons now I will get one back but I
want to be annoying I'll get one back
this pond I'm gonna get back I'm not
worried about that but I didn't want to
really have to deal with pond takes for
one it helps out this bishop I don't
know that I want to allow this bishop to
come out and another is that after this
is captured when I play my rook on the
e-file let's just do it when I play my
rook here there's gonna be some issue
right this is gonna be a little bit
uncomfortable also there's other temple
gaining moves such as Bishop g4 hitting
the Queen I think there's a good reply
however just to simply develop Knight f3
but there's two pins so what are you
gonna do now I couldn't take the bishop
on the last turn right my pod was pinned
to my king but now that's not the case
so rook e8 is a model I'm thinking about
Bishop g4 this is this is big trouble
now for for white this is really big
trouble now this pawn is he had to be
taken I'm pretty sure you had to just
take him and then kind of oh maybe maybe
there was gonna be a problem with still
rook here a knight here maybe that's
what my opponent was seeing now I think
time is number one factor so I don't
want to retreat I want to just get the
move back and queen takes or Knight
takes I like Knight takes I'm looking at
f2 I'm also looking at c3 so I'm
actually not down any material I up
material 1 2 3 4 I'm not down it's even
material but I have a leading
development and I'm looking to pick up
another pawn Knight out Bishop here you
know what I could have considered come
to think of it maybe I should have
developed my bishop too
for temporarily making use of my nights
position on f6 and only then taken on
this square but they should still be
good take this pawn and I'm hitting the
Queen and is there something better
yeah I'm really a little bit upset with
myself for not playing my Bishop to g4
prior to capturing on d5 I could have
gotten more out of my development I
could have gotten more out of my Knights
position Knight here there's counter
attacking moves I think it should still
just be good let's just take it this is
the one this is the bishop that I need
to be concerned about this bishop more
than this one the one that's unopposed I
don't have a dark square bishop that
could counteract this dark square bishop
so pawn push is the first thing that
comes to mind that that's just helping
white to speed up development so just
retreat he's still in a spot where he
could come here here to hit the Queen I
want to get my knight out in my bishop I
just want a complete development not
look I don't have any in-depth plan here
just complete development and things
should be perfect so in that earlier
move Bishop g4 Knight f3 would have been
the move played but I would still like
to have had a bishop developed so this
isn't a safe home I don't know he's a
good defender
let's get a night out I was for a second
thinking here that still might be on the
cards
you know we're castled on opposite side
so okay this weakens the light squares
him I don't have to worry about as much
now this square I'd really like to get
to this Square and here right here to
here
let's go Queen here this seems very
active I'm threatening pawn push with
check winning material and she has
lateral movement so I could shift her
over to this Queen side alright so he
gets out of that this was actually the
other threat however after Bishop here
Queen here I'm in a pin no but I could
get out no I can't get out of it let's
let's do Knight here actually yeah let
me hit the Queen a little bit I'm open
to a queen trade if Queen here I'll take
Knight here looking at this this is a
passed pawn and he's kind of a dead
piece on b2 I'm one move away from being
fully developed just need to get this
Bishop out and I should probably just do
this right away
sure I missed something better it seemed
like there should have been some some
way to get a bigger advantage ooh and I
can't move my knight cuz I'd be dropping
h7 missed that yeah I don't want to deal
with that
I've also weakened my dark square
diagonal I have to be very cautious of
this guy there might be some sacrifice
here one day and the other row coming
over and then down here made on each 8
g4 seems like the best reply this this
Bishop I'm really worried about
let's just go here Fein code night okay
I want to make sure that this file does
not open up so that's why I'm planting a
bishop on g4 locking this little lock
down on that get my rook working this
bishop can't go too far because the
pressure I have on the knight
I just want to get my rook here 30
seconds shouldn't be too much of an
issue here he can't go too far he's
pinning this pawn and now Knight takes
here as a threat let me get out of that
and has to be an easier way okay I'm
working myself right into a fork this
should still be good actually though
because I have very very good squares
for my minor pieces this knight in
particular is very very strong but it's
never really gonna come down to that
Plus this bishop is also really good
five seconds it's got a pre move
anything oh my goodness I could have
taken that that was an ugly game I must
say it was it was ugly on just all over
both both sides I think we both could
have done a lot better well let's go
back here I got really really messy is
the time wound down as well
I was just mouse tactics so this is
really uh this is really the fault beer
counter gambit do I have that right
no the exact move order I know
early on it said it said what it said
Vienna Falk beer and variations so just
these two pawns when there's this
tension the
f-4e 4 vs e 5 and D 5 when there's this
tension I'm reminded of the Falk beer
counter gambit I don't know I really
again I really don't know much about
this I know that you really just have to
pay close attention to time it's the big
thing in this position that has now been
blown open we need to get developed and
this is going in the wrong direction I'm
pretty sure I think you should just take
it as soon as this move is played
instead of Queen here just take it I get
this pawn back and then you can come
back here I think that's going to be a
better road for you to go down clearly
something's wrong if you have to pin the
pawn and then go back home like this
maybe it was the correct decision at
this point mmm although I don't know
about that I'm not sure I know there's
gonna be some trouble for you too and
you know so it's still some problems for
you to solve along the e-file if Bishop
takes rook e8 with moves like Knight g4
to follow but I was thinking after
Bishop takes after rook e8 maybe you can
it's tough actually I was thinking rook
e8 Bishop takes I'm sorry Bishop takes
pawn rook EA Knight f3 preparing to play
Knight e5 to block off this diagonal but
this move is gonna turn out to be very
strong yeah if Bishop takes pawn rook e8
Knight takes here is a very strong
threat hitting at c3 threatening to take
twice with the fork on the king and rook
as well as just converging on the e3
Square and on what would then be the
bishop on e3
hmm yeah this is trouble now and oh I'm
get back to this point right here this
is what I was emphasizing during the
game should get a little bit more out of
my Knights position Bishop g4 and only
then take Bishop g4 Knight f3 but then I
could take here and after I capture on
this square the Queen would have to move
here's another benefit of having the
bishop here on g4 and the knight being
on f3 it's that when I do capture on f4
after I get this pawn I will get this
pawn back after I capture on f4 I'll be
attacking the Queen and she has to go
back home she's not able to do similar
to what she did in this game namely make
a move that's counter attacking
eventually what happened I took the pawn
and the Queen moved and threw a punch
right back at my knight and maybe I had
even something better but I think it's
still getting all the way back to this
point right here Queenie to just take
that pawn right away take on e3 and then
come back after Jim Knight takes here
come back to d2 you're still up upon you
have some work to do it's more difficult
for you to develop your pieces bit more
smooth on my end but that's the
give-and-take and you're up upon you
have to struggle in some way that's
that's my compensation I have a little
smoother development quicker development
for the material invested and well yeah
I really didn't want to trade Queens and
it seems there's so many holes over here
but I really couldn't get at that King
so easily and I had to be careful and
we're just going crazy here you're up
the exchange still still should be kind
of tricky because of this everything is
locked down this pawn Bishop and pawn
here
but uh we're just playing for time stuff
now Messi at the very very end okay
good game
you